hallo mein name ist lukom ich musste
meinem wortschatz vielleicht habt ihr
das video gesehen mein neues auto wo ich
euch mein neues auto präsentiert habe
ich zeige ihnen jede person die es
mindestens bis zur mitte geschaut hat
weiß dass das ganze nur einen leihwagen
war den ich testweise von porsche
bekommen habe für so ein event
allerdings bestanden ca 90 der
kommentare daraus dass leute meinten
borders bis zu verachtender spaß dass du
so ein auto gekauft hat wo bist du dumm
dass man das kennzeichen sieht und noch
viele andere kommentare deswegen hab ich
mir gedacht ich suche jetzt aber ein
paar kommentare raus die ich euch mal
präsentiere und sage am ende noch was zu
dem ganzen thema let's go fische flu
schreibt habe zuerst gedacht das wäre
ein job
die geilsten job das brauchst du nicht
nur erst zuerst denken ich meine so
viele haben in die kommentare
geschrieben
du sparst was kaufst du dir denn so ein
auto freunde wenn ihr das video
mindestens wenn ihr das video mindestens
bis minute zwei minuten 13 gesehen
hättet ihr hättet app bin ich denn
bekannte ich gar nicht ergeben
da habe ich doch nur gesagt das ist mein
auto ich wollte jetzt einfach mal zeigen
nein spaß schreiben wirklich also da
sind über 10.000 kommentare unter dem
video damit so viele geschrieben warum
kaufst du dir schon freunde her egal wir
machen weiter ein auto kann nur 280 ps
eigentlich höchstens haben oder haben es
nur habe ich gehört und dadurch hat man
auch schon ab da gemerkt dass es nur ein
spaß war deine aussage können autos also
höchstens 280 ps haben ja gut ich meine
dass google doch einfach mal autos mit
über 280 ps und ich glaube du wirst
etwas film 18 plus schneller
ein flugzeug ist auch schnell eine
rakete es auch schneller soll als
nächstes der rakete hat einen scheiß man
über eine million aufrufe nur wegen
sonnen in klammern auto
umweltverschmutzer eine frage liebe
kinder was findet ihr ein kontrast gut
dass er so geheilt wird von euch danke
für deinen kommentar sascha straub m
hier dachte es tatsächlich berechtigte
frage die stelle ich mir selber sehr
häufig und das frage ich mich
tatsächlich auch selbst warum guckt ihr
mich also ich kann deine aussage
komplett verstehen ich weiß es auch
nicht aber ich glaube einfach dass ist
ein bisschen dieses ich bin total spaß
und alle denken ich bin ein totaler spaß
und laut dir anscheinend auch ein
umweltverschmutzer selbst schickes auto
allgemein finde ich dass man porsche
schon zu den alltagsautos zählen kann
dieser porsche hat 350 ps und die
endgeschwindigkeit beträgt 289 km/h von
null auf hundert geht der porsche in 4 8
sekunden und der wii 1380 kilogramm und
der motor ist ein sechszylinder mit 3387
kubik hubraum und der körper ist ein
coupé
danke für deine ganzen information die
hast du bestimmt gar nicht von google
scheint die antwort von wiki lobby
gaming darauf auch sehr cool er
vollendet nämlich nochmal diese lange
aussage von christoph hahn schreibt und
du hast keine hobbys wir haben das
gleiche auto und ein lamborghini und ich
will der papst das ist eure kommentare
die antworten ich könnte jeden tag
kommentare video
warum zeigt er sein kennzeichen man kann
über programme dann den wohnsitz
rausbekommen alles klar
lieber dann vorn haben ist doch nicht
feiern lieber feiert dann google doch
einfach mal das kennzeichen spo 4001 es
steht nämlich bei stuttgart wo porsche
sitzt timo steht für geschäftsbereich
öffentlichkeitsarbeit also ist es ein
auto was für presse menschen leihweise
et cetera herausgegeben wird und 4001
einfach eine zahl wenn man laut deiner
aussage meinen wohnsitz herausfinden
würde würde ich wurde den porsche werken
wohnen in irgendeinem karosserieteil
oder so aber ja also manche leute
sollten tatsächlich ihre aussagen weil
überdenken der lollipop fan schreibt das
ist eh nicht deiner darauf kommt die
antwort ach schlaubi wie wärs mal das
video ganz anzuschauen
darauf geht der blondschopf wieder ein
und schreibt keine zeit
ja also er ist quasi auf das video
gegangen nur um zu schreiben das ist
nicht deine und ist an dem die
abgecheckt mag ich es heute leute
arrogante art schleust dir ein teures
auto und andere müssen jeden cent
zweimal umdrehen ist spaßig lauf mir
einfach ein teures auto manuel schreibt
neue strings wir bei jedem m einen
schluck nehmen
gross habe ich mich als ob ich so offen
gesagt habe
gleich eins aufs maul sieht viel besser
aus als der von red ja wann weiß auch so
ein toller r8 ist mario fragt wo hast du
es geliehen es ist ein porsche
wahrscheinlich habe ich den beim
fahrradverleih nebenan geliehen oder
zwischen mireille buer gharani schreibt
bilder von sollen machen alle einen
daumen runter
alles klar kein sind auch nach mehr sie
können nachdenken macht macht
tatsächlich keinen sinn oha wie viele
aufrufe dummer kriegst und likes mit
diesem zwingers weil ich viele aufruf
würde mal kriegst aufruf und likes
aufrufs der letzte kommentar auf den ich
eigentlich möchte kommt von teese und
zwar schreibt er hast du den bar bezahlt
erst mal darauf die akkus über 140000
euro wenn ich den bar bezahlen würde
müsste ich mit sonnen batzen geld da
hingehen oder so oder mit sommer wachsen
geld das dann hat er wahrscheinlich das
video zu ende geschaut und schreibt
danach gehört dir nicht das was sind das
für kommentare mal als 99 prozent die
kommentarschreiber haben glaube ich
einfach nur das video angeklickt um
einen kommentar zu schreiben
und haben dann das video zu ende
geschaut und haben sich damit berechtigt
weil sie gesehen haben oder gehört die
mir gar nicht das war alles nur ein fake
das war also eine parodie freunde
pandaria base es ist nicht mein porsche
ich habe mir nicht so ein teures auto
gekauft noch mal zur erklärung porsche
hat mir den vor zehn tage gegeben weil
ich ja mit dem hockenheim
ringen waren dort wissen was erleben
durfte ein video machen durfte und die
hatten da bock drauf ich hatte da bock
drauf ich musste den fortschritt
allerdings wieder abgeben ich falls
wieder mit meinem normalen auto rum und
habe den porsche nicht mehr allerdings
habe ich jetzt sehr viele neue älter die
meinen dass sich porsche fahrer und
außen abgehobene youtuber bin ich die
alle auch porsche boxster gts fahren das
ist nicht der fall ich bin immer noch
luca ich fahre karton
ich fahr karton also und an dieser
stelle beende ich auch schon das video
meine damen und herren kreativen die
kommentare die durch am ende mag
klatsche das ist nicht unser ganze
symphonie zu synchronisieren
die tonspuren und so miteinander sondern
ist es einfach nur so da mittwoch
kienbaum
jetzt kommt die verabschiedung ende ihr
werdet euch das mit den kommentaren
wieder gefallen hat würde ich mich über
eine bewertung freundschaft und meine
kommentare ob ihre böse kommentare lesen
vorlesen video nochmal wolle weil ich
habe wieder sehr viele gefunden das will
ich dann die tage hochladen